é a chave que a redução só são 9 33 da
manhã a fotografar este logo porque no
fim de semana eu vou pro porto e
prontinho de se gravar qualquer coisa
pra vocês tudo feito por mission eu
tenho que ir à casa de banho
vejam como eu deixei você não tem a
noite é assim que isto fica por fazer
panquecas sim o companhia já à noite mas
vocês vão passar o dia comigo eu vou
tentar filmar aquilo que eu conseguir
e no fim de semana também vai ser uma
ficha que o banco de micro ondas não não
vou ter que fazer o mesmo sério eu
gostaria de tuning antes que uma loja de
uma amiga minha que é escaldante ela
convidou a minha ea se tricampeão em 6
vocês vão perceber o tom falou hoje eu
vou te colocar o gás que é nova e nem só
com uma mão é impossível a sério e que
ela não pode só falar ó sério gosta
vejo o meu cobertor é do som do álcool e
do técnico é genial e do internacional
ocupa pequenino e dentro do longa
não sei se vocês sabem mas eu estou
inquieto começou coisas saudáveis por
isso que eu tenho em casa todo mundo
gosta pouco medo
vejam a quantidade de corte que fazer na
hora e ficou um vídeo de seis minutos e
ainda tem que ditar este pecado todo
porque como vocês podem ver que está
tudo editado e isso ainda não estava o
corte ainda tenho por isso vamos tem
pressa porque preto ela e sim só dava
trabalho agora de manhã
eu preciso ter despachado a uma ação
neste momento 10
eu não sei se vou conseguir ganhar este
tempo mas eu vim para o japão acaba de
editar o vídeo agora e isso é um 10 e 45
mil e tentei isso muito rápido eu
pensava que o ignorar mais tempo mas não
o meu quarto tipo que o exemplo de
quando vocês não têm as coisas meu
desenhar os cães por cá a solução eu
tenho uma campanha dentro do quarto por
causa do barulho eu tenho uma câmera que
se dobra vejo esta [ __ ] dobras e tem
que vão fazer de tudo
nesta campanha quando o ps de estar aqui
eu abri a cama e vai tomar vontade e
continua a ter umas passa mesmo por ser
um texto aqui mesmo uma câmera nem
espaço para andar aqui o mal já está
feito e agora vou ver se o vídeo já fiz
de renda e é já realizou tudo para ser
caso haveria já fez upload já conhece
maioria por isso eu tenho que me
despachar já consigo dia como é usar eu
tô sem dinheiro para o autocarro e eu
tentei levantar o dinheiro atrás meu chá
máquina estava ligada o que quer dizer
que vou ter que andar esta [ __ ] toda
porque não é mais máquinas multibanco
vou ter que andar até ao fundo -
esperemos que a máquina tinha dinheiro
porque se não tiver dinheiro não vou
conseguir apanhar o autocarro e se eu
não conseguir apanhar o autocarro não
vou estar lá tempo e se não tiver lá
tempo eu perco com bóia vida ver uma
caixa de multibanco pra eles saem 100
metros uma coisa assim
isto queria ter que andar um quilômetro
só pancada dinheiro rito canção eu vou
correr que assim mais rápido e faz
exercício que eu estou gordo nem precisa
disso
o fox quer para os monstros tudo para
conseguir dinheiro pro fucking do
autocarro a cantora não liga para dizer
que não vêm cá buscar corri para caraças
por ter dinheiro e final vou tocar minha
vida é uma bosta ser finalmente chegou
ao gol
vamos filmar a data porque 100% para
blogs não é bom não é uma opção boa
mesmo tempo que bom né ainda não como
nós com dentro do carro ainda absolver
tiragem
no entanto geral maceió
estamos agora é aqui em sampa km ea
instituição
vamos agora comprar os bilhetes por
tentou pegar a mala de alguém não é
depois de virar pressa para tentar
arranjar um bilhete para um boy o
comboio estava escutava por isso estou
numa esplanada onde se sabe não mas
ainda não chegou comigo eu estou aqui
conquistei né
já vi na minha vida toda foi no carro é
a no carro que eu tava teriam direito se
já amanhã subir será de bom humor e eu
virei nannerl israelense e esse tipo de
ato legal nesse tipo de hegemonia se não
desse evento que merece ficar duas horas
à espera
só por este clube que eu tenho muito
medo é que só faltava isso era por
morrer ou ficar sem bateria só faltava
isso mas pronto vejo aqui na esplanada
foi ao chão e vamos comer o quê picanha
os a mão a quem eu fiquei aguardando um
ganha-ganha explicar as roupas usadas né
assim uma pessoa vai ficar no atacado
que estão devendo
pode ser uma
o segredo é você pegando uma linha que a
coca brynco johnny é pode ser
e foi por isso que ele foi embora
mantenha gregos o ipca-e dentro do jogo
eo ponto por causa do design é uma
segredo né não olhe eu já vou olha-me
sptel gostoso
posso entrar
já estamos em um domínio muito escrever
a nossa risco é não dar lugar à janela
que no entanto não é chanel a minha
disse que vai trabalhar e não sabe que
eu sei eu tenho que ser uma pessoa que
já estamos no porto né
e agora vamos sentar porque o cheiro de
forma e tem muita gente aqui meu deus
tanta gente e vamos ver o que vamos ser
honestos
não acho isso justo é mesmo só o frank
um país crucial pois são nem eu te amo é
só salvar a frio aqui em cascavel
ela diz que os linha da bola e não tá
aqui chegamos aqui nef na quinta-feira o
estado em gansi que é uma loja aqui no
porto linha da marca dos carros ainda
não os três garotos que ela está lá
embaixo fazer um boxe de coisas é que a
loja bonita tanta cozinha pelos tiros
pois a escola enquanto fora
agora o que tem aqui o melhor que é
princesa xuxa a roche não existe e que
está aqui é o rio da casca
ela já não é via judicial
agora sim é um action figure como action
figure ea china têm uma acção figueira
lei ou porta-chaves froza cruza o céu
não é chega a alma não olhassem pra mim
está implantou fazer aqui também
meu deus pai não posso ter o principal
acesso móvel ao rei aqui e agora estou
esperando que o shopping como coxa
o hamas num mesmo posso comer ou ferir o
que era aquilo
será um cosplay será um eco não é assim
olá chato jantar estamos aqui com o
vocalista dos linkin park chester e que
ficaram lá dona dão aquela final que não
é com a segurança
hoje temos aqui também na do canal
sempre pior se a polícia não sabe que
está começando agora já que o mesmo seja
feito tantas peças terão quem pouco não
flamengo né
olha a imagem do deus tanto comigo e eu
dar a conhecer o gramado quando é que
você vai roubar a câmera foi campeão
italiano mesmo que nós queremos
xuxa porque elas ficaram e comer sushi
porque nós já estavam cheios e nós
viemos aqui fora fazer coisas do homem
e tu fumacê e e uma mota
nós temos cameron ea doyle ea dóia sushi
e da história entre japoneses e vai
pessoa que nos juntar e já achamos que o
hotel estão nos quarto ambos tanto
agradável a câmera em idosas
eu tenho que estudar interna que eu não
sei bem como é que isso funciona né é
pequenino gostoso até a casa de banho o
que posso fazer campanha está ok
xavi eu não quero arriscar e minha casa
também as mulheres não podem criar o
prosub favor nunca alguém no crédito o
que que o gol eo pop posso usar o que vi
aqui na casa de banho e só agora é que o
upgrade eu vim pra quem a pensar ok eu
vou ficar aqui vou tomar um belo de um
fato de banho mas só pôde ir lá por aí
o bairro é que tipo junto com o bebê e
com a sanita que eu vou tomar banho da
sanita e não perceber isto significa que
pode tomar banho enquanto o cargo ao
mesmo tempo de palavra
então é isso pessoal isto foi sexta
feira eu pensava em fazer mais golos só
de mim boca e vocês não estarão neste
dia hoje sábado mas isto foi feito na
sexta feira e este foi o fim do blog
porque já à noite eu agora vou ter que
limitar o estudo agora enquanto ela vai
dormir porque ela não edita as coisas
não têm para mim é bastante perfumes
peritagem e aí nós estamos cansados
possui um dos cargos até que assim eles
terão sete mandamentos não é tamanho que
essa mesma já salva enquanto o vasco
segue favorito fique bem e é é a simão
eu não faço gol eu faço votos para que o
vídeo